grief is a taboo
because death is a taboo death it's one
of the few things that all human beings
have to go through
so why do you rarely talk about it grief
it's a full body full being experienced
in western culture grief can be treated
like a dirty secret
but it's something that's completely
natural i think it's important to speak
about
grief because it normalizes death
i wanted to find out why grief is a
taboo subject
whether a wider understanding of it
could help people and what countries
like the uk
can learn from different cultures around
the world
everyone that knew ewan would
distinctively remember him for his
bright blue eyes and his cheeky laugh
ellie and ewan were friends from birth
he was very funny
always making jokes and anyone that knew
him
um loved him he just had that sort of
sense of charm about him ewan died in
may 2020
in the middle of the uk's first covert
19 lockdown
he was 18 years old it obviously was
such a shock to us all
some of my close friends had never been
through deaf before at all
since kind of like their first almost
encounter with it we
became really close like such a close
knit group of friends
and it has kind of all made us realize
that life is too short and to not take
anything for granted
ellie and her friends supported each
other during lockdown with zoom calls
and when it was allowed meeting up in
person
going through this um it changed you as
a person
and it's changed all of us as people um
and i think we've kind of got a bond
that is going to stay with us for life
going through that with these people i
literally don't think i'd be here
without them because they helped me so
much
grief it's a full body full being
experience
that affects us on multiple levels the
first being the mental
the second being the physical the third
being the emotional
and the fourth being the spiritual level
i first became fully aware of grief in
2016 when my dad andy died
suddenly me and my family were thrown
into this new world
it's like being in a secret club that no
one wants to join
it has its own language own groups but
no one outside of it ever talks about it
grief is something that's incredibly
challenging to talk about for a lot of
people and ends up being taboo
because we really get challenged and we
get
held up by the fact that we want to do
the right thing we want to say the right
thing and we want to know
exactly how to address someone's grief
or how to address the topic of death
since the covert 19 pandemic
more and more people have joined that
grief club i think it's really hard
to talk about this because we don't know
where to start sometimes
but the thing that i recommend is just
starting somewhere and starting with
people that you're comfortable
with and safe with but not everyone has
a strong support network
around one in four british adults they
wish their friends would talk more about
their loved one who had died
and one in fives if they felt lonely
after a bereavement
as well as that more than 50 percent of
people said they were scared of saying
the wrong thing to someone who's
recently lost their loved one
it was loved by all especially everybody
in the community not just from myself
and
my sisters and the rest of our family
members
is one of those people that everyone
sort of looked up to
former rugby league player wayne
initially struggled to talk about his
grief
his dad desmond died in january 2020.
me personally um i tend to all stuff
quite in a lot when my dad passed away i
could
i could sort of feel inside of things
bottling up
and i didn't sort of want that to to
explode inside me to make me feel even
worse
lots of people struggle to open up about
their emotions
but men in particular have a hard time
58 of men feel like they're expected to
be emotionally strong and show no
weakness
and 38 have even avoided talking about
their feelings
out of fear of being unmanly but
as wayne found out speaking about things
can really help
i sort of got my
my feelings off my chest by speaking to
friends more so than family
um it's it's definitely important to
speak about because like i say if you
bottle it up too much
it can make things worse and now i'm i'm
coping
i'm i'm dealing with it and it's it's
something that i've got i've got to live
with so
so yeah our grief experience can be
shaped by many different parts of our
identity whether that's
our race our gender identity our place
in the world like our location
our culture our background our family
our class our
income it can be impacted by so many
pieces of what make us us for the rest
of our lives
dealing with death is a universal
experience but in the uk it's often
hidden away
but that isn't the case elsewhere in the
[Music]
world
just south of mexico city san andreas
meets kick
is famous for day of the dead the
ceremony celebrates the souls of dead
loved ones returning to the world of the
living
and they're welcome with colorful feasts
and huge celebrations
people build shrines for their loved
ones and even cook their favorite meals
but in 2020 much like a lot of things
the ceremony was very different
it's traditional to visit cemeteries and
leave offerings on graves
but because of covert 19 this had to be
scaled back
some families lost a lot of loved ones
to the pandemic
and for them it was an important year to
mark the day of the dead
but it isn't just mexico that approaches
death and grief so openly
erica struggled with her grief after
finding her father-in-law dead
at his house she became fascinated with
so-called death festivals around the
world
so much so she started a visit
amazing place i went to indonesia it's
um an area called tana taraja which is
very
it's a landlocked remote region of
indonesia and there
um every year they will actually exhume
the dead from the crips and they will
give them new clothes and walk them
around and everyone's taking photos
people are face timing you know like
facetiming relatives who couldn't make
made it but i saw this woman she was sat
next to her grandmother who'd been dead
for four years
and there was this moment where she just
looked at her and saw a bit of dust in
her hair
and she just brushed it away and i had
this moment of
thinking i forgot about the love
like all of this is based on love
[Music]
the death vessel in nepal is called
gaijatra which literally translates to
cow festival
so um the point of gaijatra is that
everybody who's lost somebody that year
will join a procession through the
streets of kathmandu
the biggest lie that grief tells you is
that you're alone
this drowning loneliness that
accompanies bereavement and it's
actually pretty difficult to feel like
you're alone
when you're looking out over thousands
of people
who are dancing through the streets
because they've been through the exact
same thing as you and they've been
through it this year
so in madagascar every five to seven
years um
the family will go to the family tomb
pull out the
dead bodies and wrap them in a new
shroud and then they'll put them on
their shoulders and dance around again
there's a big band there's loads of
music everyone's getting drunk
and it is utterly joyful there's a lot
of things we can learn from death
festivals around the world
death is ordinary it's painful but
here we sort of talk about it as if it's
an aberration every time as if
something's gone horribly awry the other
thing we should learn
is that when someone dies you have your
grief and your loss but you're also
dealing with
a death reminder you're dealing with
mortality itself and that is a stressful
thing
you shouldn't leave it until someone's
died or you yourself are dying
we should be able to just mention it
easily it shouldn't be rude
to mention death but in western culture
it is something we struggle to talk
about in fact
around two-thirds of people think we do
not open up enough about death in the uk
one of the things that we can do in
general to make it
less challenging to address is just
getting comfortable with the fact that
we're all gonna have to wait our way
through it
people though confront it every single
day
i work for marie curie and rapid
response service
basically we're at the end of the
telephone for what people need overnight
with regards to when to life and
palliative care jill goes to people's
houses to help treat them at the end of
life
she deals with death on a daily basis
and says it's given her a new
perspective on him
i know i'm a lot more comfortable around
death and dying
and it's not something you shouldn't
speak about
we don't we don't talk enough about
about death and diner until it sort of
smacks you in the face if you like you
avoid it
um but but we shouldn't when somebody's
in the last
that last stage of life and you see
them accept the fact that
death's imminent and you see
that more of a weight lifted they relax
that would also happen with family and
things it's important
but it isn't just medical professionals
who have decided to confront death and
grief in their everyday lives
[Music]
dan and his twin brother tom formed the
van architects back in 2004.
tom died of skin cancer in 2016 aged 28.
he was the main songwriter of the group
so dan took up that position
i was given this vehicle to help process
my grief when you go to write an album
you i suppose you write about whatever
is most important to you or whatever is
most
prominent in your life and obviously
everything was eclipsed by
um tom's death and so it was the only
thing
i could write about but it was it was a
gift
to me
the songs dan wrote about his grief with
titles like death is not defeat
mortal after all and doomsday connecting
with fans around the world
every night we would see hundreds or
thousands of people
in tears you know the whole front row i
could see balling their eyes out and it
was like i'd become
like some like a death digger or some
kind of grief guru
which i wasn't you know i was just
um obviously being vulnerable i was
being vulnerable in front of people i
didn't know
when my brother was sick i used to think
a lot about this
about being here specifically behind the
stage with my brother
telling him i couldn't believe that we
were here the band openly discussed
grief and loss on stage
and their live shows have become
emotionally charged events
i've been in these crowds and i can tell
you it's a different experience to any
other gig you'll go to
thank you so much but for dan
this emotional response from audiences
proves why it's so important to talk
about grief
it ought to be spoken about um
in a very real and honest way i think
it's important to speak about
grief because it normalizes death
everyone i spoke to agreed that grief
and death are taboo subjects
because it reminds people of their own
mortality and
i get why that's uncomfortable it isn't
something you want to think about all
the time
but hiding it away isn't healthy there's
no
right way to do it but speaking openly
about grief whether you're on a stage
at a death festival or even just
chatting with friends on a zoom call can
be so important
it's something we're all going to
experience in one way or the other
so we might as well get ready for it i
absolutely do not believe that there is
a right way to grieve or a normal way to
grieve
or a typical way that everyone grieves
it's not
something to be scared of or feel
awkward about
it's definitely important to speak about
because like i say if you bottle it up
too much
it can make things worse the sooner we
can
embrace that the sooner we'll be able to
live better happier lives
and certainly in my experience live
lives
with more purpose
you